[Music]
this video describes EQ radio a new
technology from Professor Catawbas group
at MIT that can recognize people's
emotions using wireless signals was
there a moment in your life when you
looked at someone's face but you could
not figure out how they feel what if
your wireless router can tell people's
emotions even if they don't show them on
their faces this is exactly what our
technology does this is our device the
device transmits a wireless signal which
reflects off a person's body and comes
back it captures these reflections and
analyzes them to infer the person's
emotions specifically our algorithms
zoom in on the wireless reflections to
extract the minut variations due to
breathing and heartbeat we then further
analyze these reflections to extract the
breathing signal and the heartbeat
signal we then zoom in more on these
signals to obtain individual heartbeats
and breathing cycles and feed these s
features into a machine learning
algorithm to recognize a person's
emotions the device can automatically
know if the present is excited angry sad
or happy our device can recognize
motions with an accuracy of 87% why
lying
purely on wireless signals we envision
that EQ radio can be used in many
applications it can recognize a person's
emotions while he is watching a movie
and provide movie makers with better
tools to evaluate user experience it can
also allow smart environments to detect
emotional states like depression and
inform us to improve our emotional
well-being it can even enable these
environments to react to our moods and
adjust lighting or music accordingly
[Music]
to learn more about this research please
check out our website
[Music]